local dance team honored
martin luther king jr's breakfast award
mary jane belliesa shares how priceless
diamonds is navigating through this
pandemic with community involvement and
each other
for the priceless diamonds majorette
dance team every step and every flap
shows unity and the power of teamwork
dance director melissa ross started
priceless diamonds in august 2015. kids
wanted to dance so
i just you know involved more kids to
come and join when i first started mom
stephanie felton says the group
instantly became a family from the start
i was literally there with her on the
bed when she came up with colors a name
and her recruitment and i was in her
first studio actually and their talent
definitely shows so far the team has
over 90 trophies even winning best
community dance group at this year's
martin luther king jr parade but
assistant secretary mandisha shanks says
kova 19 has brought on financial
struggles making it hard for them to
travel to competitions we do
acts for
donations or sponsorships it's been real
hard over the years because we haven't
been able to get them
so it's been
coming out of the pockets of the parents
and the director omla don sears says it
hasn't been easy but is proud of
everything they've accomplished so far
people you know go and come and kids
growing up on the team since they was
like real little and priceless diamonds
isn't slowing down anytime soon even
through this pandemic the team credits
their brotherhood sisterhood and
perseverance to get them through any
challenge they face everybody be like
how you do it
god
god mary jane ballieza live local now
and make sure to tune in for 8 news now
special honoring black history next
month that airs on saturday february 5th
at 6 30 p.m